okay [ __ ] it's your boy psychobabble
and we're am continuing the last of us
okay we just met bell it's loading so I
got lil time at acting out okay let's
see here I way way way too much make the
Huddle's and normally I can take it but
this time I ate it sideways I was lying
down supplies you may want or need oh
okay thank you basically I was lying
down on those bad and I just started
pushing it to my mouth didn't even make
sense oh what the [ __ ] that was my
special woman um and I think that just
kind of messed things up for me you know
um should actually get it i'll take my
tie a little knot like this that i got
that yeah and yeah yeah anyways how was
your day what is this my rifle ammo
ships are upgraded what I just like a
book I guess okay this I'm going to
reload this I can't thank ya um shut
that's fully I could it is that raining
outside I you some more Chet okay what
can I make her up quick I know you and
now you wanna know maximum I help that
tank yeah yeah got good in the style
just haul off to it as I knead it you
know oh [ __ ] okay okay it's time to get
God can I get God all right anything
else you saw yet oh so I get some
ketchup she doesn't get you I put a lot
of catch up with my friend rise today I
said I am gonna be the master of my own
destiny good [ __ ] Bell you don't look
too good now bit so Sigma come on I
thought here's have a [ __ ] lock her
out don't leave the door open I got it
not really weird kind of cut scene
what's the stairs move it you just want
to really go stay with me can't believe
he agreed to this [ __ ] bill what you
should have done was just left him back
there what kind of trouble aren't you in
where the hell's tags will of the king
are you delivered haha [ __ ] you too Oh
yeah kidding me with this guy where we
going bill I like the main character a
lot more of an armory we you know how to
fix a kind of tech like I said guns I
feel like there's poly penance and [ __ ]
here right how does this good again oh
that's tempting but no one side okay so
you didn't answer my question about Tess
yeah I thought the two of you were
inseparable she's busy yeah sure busy
that she says like he's happy liquid
noice ounces when I'm masturbating its
Rick yes I'm like that sad join chris
said drank this just to freak them out
you know again
so why do you fix one of these cars oh
my god you're a genius I mean the whole
time why on berna [ __ ] decks in one of
these cars okay don't be a dick their
tires are rotted and the batteries are
dead are you done gaining begin to think
what the inside of the engine blocks
look like making new car batteries or
the military
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I got share beds rod rod
gut gut I got to fetch my gosh yeah yeah
suck and bread out all right and all the
supplies from the warehouse of Legends
yeah skinny legs yeah Joel this way
where are the [ __ ] an item sons dad I
was so sure there's a hidden items no
Jesus Ricky it's good it's just like I
had a breath he's like huffing it's been
like 10 hours I'm still [ __ ]
Department chat picked a hell of a place
to hole up in you know as bad as those
things are at least they're predictable
scare me yeah I would taking this thank
you nothing Tommy Tommy's an [ __ ]
isn't he hey what do you want what's
this could put this guy down what the
[ __ ] you know what I think this game is
really the gates gonna hold him well
done I don't have a key I just think the
one weakness is the [ __ ] in an audio
like I mean I am using I think here the
seller is this ok oh I like that you can
overlook it down helen is my girlfriend
Jessica and that she's on sleeping for
miles no here we are you don't touch
anything and you close the door [ __ ]
an [ __ ] let's gear up uh uh what I
need a gun no you don't Joel I can
handle myself no just stays what why
don't think you've her come [ __ ] fine
just wait around for you two to get me
killed well this goes on record is the
worst [ __ ] job you've ever taken it's
up there on the hell is test okay with a
suicide mission actually her idea really
well the Broads not as smart as I
thought she was what [ __ ] ah Jesus
seriously you got to take that kid back
to where you found her I can't just take
her back and send her packing let her
find her own way let me tell you a story
once upon a time I had somebody that I
cared about his penis
the partner somebody I had to look after
and in this world that sort of [ __ ] good
for one thing get you killed Oh God God
so you know what I did why isn't the
[ __ ] up I realized it's got to be just
me bill today anything like that it's
[ __ ] is just like that hey what I
said you we walk down the steps what I
say just fixing your stupid pile don't
tie chase s god damn it you keep
babysitting long enough and eventually
it's gonna blow up in their face can we
please just get on all right here
chuckles get on with it oh very nice I
before we go any further I got something
I got to show you is there that comes to
god it's like a bench deck and I upgrade
my [ __ ] huh why are you upgrading oh my
god she was organizing the sex magazines
be Ken is that like a is he that gay
porn Wow beef can that is [ __ ] insane
wow really good easter egg here when she
was over here though and i'll just be
running around here this is a no board
no and i love that i like my board
I'll have to just [ __ ] go like what
the [ __ ] seriously what the hell why is
your like so much space to like explore
ah it's a man jay says the [ __ ] is this
okay so I guess I should be trusting in
the Lord um you know it's that's good
i'll take what is that marijuana mom's
now okay i guess this game was trying to
be like not have any drama because
there's no Jesus figures here in this
church it just lower case letter tease
so there's that what's up there a lot of
exploring to do look oh okay not thank
you now thank you I guess he has no toy
I love toys sometimes I gotta the
walmart you go in the toy section and
get myself a toy I love toys that is it
that you want for me this is a nail bomb
you gotta be really careful this thing
blows it shreds anybody standing there
by yeah I've seen your handiwork oh
Jesus take a thousand bear scissors hmm
are one or you can tuck and throughout
okay so we got shot guns and bombs the
hell we doing with them well every three
weeks is military care of it
I assume they're out looking for
supplies you'd be amazed so we take that
battery was put it in another car bingo
I wanted to get it but he's getting
dangerous with all the infected on that
part of town good nice dance there are
some checkers in my work [ __ ] all right
George water family what is that like
act what's the wrench therefore not that
give me that there's a lot of [ __ ] here
I have to say just like a lot of [ __ ] I
kind of feel bad for just taking on a
[ __ ] too but hey he offered he offered
yeah it wasn't me it was him ok let's
let's you some oh hello Jessica ok I can
ok let's do this yeah let's do this ok
weapon oestrus whoo sure all sweet I
like this one oh [ __ ] i'm a lot though
whoo do i do it flew capacity whoo scope
power Oh Shep this one I want though hey
for [ __ ] I need SI keep [ __ ]
running out I'm gonna have a whip roar
scope sure I'm get this rifle max now
fetch okay you're good all right come
back the little toolbox Tim over here
did I swear to God if you took anything
Joel you are keeping an eye on her right
like a hawk I like Ali you feel funny
okay okay enough with the gene
commercials Bell let's go swear I've
one's character genes are so nice he's
at cargo vans oh nice place you got here
[ __ ] is he gonna baptize us would be the
place to do it okay I guess we're gonna
we're gonna end this episode here it's
very short Billy come oh yeah it's going
on here look there's a school all right
go see the next episode ladies and
gentlemen pitch out for Harambee